Speaker 1: Donald Trump has received disastrous
news from his own former lawyer, Ty Cobb.
His name is really Ty Cobb. Ty Cobb believes
Trump will end up convicted and in prison
for one of Trump's own former lawyers to say
this is really something. Donald Trump's former
attorney has boldly predicted that the former
president is going to jail as the criminal
investigation into the trove of classified
documents found at Mar a Lago continues to heat
up. Ty Cobb, who worked as a White House attorney
for the Trump administration from July 2017 to May
2018, said to CNN The evidence against Trump will
lead to a conviction and prison time. Reminder,
this is separate from Georgia, where an indictment
may be coming. This is separate from the
preexisting arrest and indictment of Trump. This
is its own. This is for the documents in Florida.
Quote, I wouldn't necessarily expand the case
to try to prove the Espionage Act piece of it,
because there's so much evidence of guilty
knowledge on the espionage piece that all
they really have to do is show that Trump move
these documents at various times when DOJ was
either demanding them or actually present that he
filed falsely with the Justice Department, had his
lawyers file falsely with the Justice Department
and affidavit to the effect that none existed,
meaning no documents, which was shattered
by the documents they discovered after the
search and the many other misrepresentations.
Yes, I do think he will go to jail on it.
Business Insider reports a former White House
lawyer believes Trump will go to jail. Ty Cobb
said there was so much evidence of guilty
knowledge. As investigations continue, the
DOJ is probing whether Trump obstructed justice
in bringing classified documents to Mar a Lago.
If other people did what Trump did, they
would certainly be prosecuted. Now, you know,
sometimes you'll see legal analysts or not.
Usually it's more like non-legal Analysts say
anybody who did this would be convicted
and sentenced to prison. Conviction is
a much different thing. Right. The criminal
standard of guilt beyond a reasonable doubt,
It's very hard to predict conviction. But what we
can say with certainty is that if other people did
what Trump did with regard to the documents, they
would certainly be prosecuted. And then we would
look at whether they get convicted. And the most
important aspect of all of this is that no one
should be above the law, should being the critical
word. The last part of this speculating on the
outcome of ongoing investigations in a sense can
be misleading. And it is true that when you hear
a lawyer like Ty Cobb say, you go, Wow, this this
is not just a random lawyer. This is not a random
left wing lawyer. This is a lawyer who worked
for Trump. And that does carry strength. And so
I think we should listen to what Ty Cobb says.
At the same time, investigations can be fickle.
These things have to run their course. We want
impartiality when it comes to the justice system.
And so when Ty Cobb makes these predictions,
they're worth noting, given his knowledge and
associations with four former President Donald
Trump. But also, we should approach all of it
with caution. Let the investigations play out and
be guided by evidence. And for the time being, I
have every reason to believe that that is exactly
what the Justice Department has been doing.
I can't imagine if you are Trump, you're thrilled
when your own former lawyer says, I think you're
going to prison. But let's wait and see, because
it's certainly one of many possible outcomes here